- You have written so many amazing songs.
Do you remember your first
song like you ever wrote?
- First song I wrote was in sixth grade.
"Here I Go Falling in Love Again."
- You were this guy in the sixth grade?
I love it.
- I was that guy in sixth grade.
Saw a girl and fell in love with her,
and I used my brother's
friend's guitar of a cousin
and it was a right-handed guitar.
I picked it up
and learned some chords and
wrote this song for her.
She never heard it.
- She never heard it?
You never played it for her?
- No, it was the first
song I wrote for her
and it was also, I
wrote two songs for her.
'Cause that was in sixth grade
and eighth grade she broke my heart
and I wrote, yeah, she did.
- Yeah, she did.
Well, where she now?
- So, I wrote my second song
called "The Bitter Taste of Life."
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- Eighth grade.
- Do you feel like,
I feel like circumstances like that,
I have something similar
whenever I was younger
that happened to me.
I still can go back to that place
and use that fuel to write.
- That's it.
That's what I use so many times
for writing songs is
all those crazy times.
- Because that depth when you're so young.
- Yep.
- And it's so...
- So passionate.
- Fresh and passionate.
'Cause people always think,
"Oh, they're too young to feel."
I'm like, you feel
everything when you're young.
- You feel it in such a big way.
- Yeah.
- And you're not jaded at that point.
- It's pure.
- Yeah.
We end up doing another song
called "Water Runs Dry."
- That's what I mean.
That's what I mean, "Water Runs Dry."
I thought that's where you were going.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Because I love how it starts out.
- So that went back, you know,
to that sixth grade kid again.
- Yeah.
Once again, maybe you should
write a thank you letter
to this lady.
Maybe we all should right now.
Just get out our Pilot
G2 Pen and go to town.
I'm just saying.
That woman helped us out tremendously
with our own relationships via your music.
- It's funny because years later
I ended up tracking her down.
- Did you?
- Yeah.
'Cause I wanted to talk to her
and see if I remembered
everything the same.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And it was pretty close.
- What did she say?
"Yeah, no, I wasn't into it."
"Yeah, no, just a real quick recap.
I didn't want you."
What did that conversation go like?
- She said that she didn't,
she ultimately said,
"I spent most of my life
always thinking about people that hurt me.
I never thought about the people
that I may have hurt along the way."
She was sorry for it.
- Write that song, sir.
- Exactly.
- That's a great lyric.
- It was a great lyric.
And I said, I said to
her, "Don't apologize.
It's because of you,
you launched the kid that
wrote a thousand songs."
- Yeah.
With 80 Grammy nominations.
It's crazy, yeah.